[Music]
on august 28 2020 news broke that
chadwick boseman
unexpectedly died at the age of 43. the
actor who was famous for playing
t'challa the mcu's black panther and
king of wakanda was easily one of the
greatest and most influential stars of
our time
bozeman passed away after a four year
long battle with colon cancer
in fact he was fighting the disease
throughout the four years he made his
last seven movies
when bozeman's official twitter account
broke the tragic news the world was in
shock
the outpouring of love from the actors
fans and fellow celebrities was
immediate and heartfelt
people paid their respects and finally
remembered his many great roles as well
as the way his role as t'challa proved
that representation matters
apart from the vast human and cultural
tragedy of bozeman's death it also
created a difficult
problem for disney and its subsidiary
marvel studios
black panther is already a billion
dollar cinematic entity and bozeman
would arguably have been the most
beloved and bankable star of the next
few phases of the marvel cinematic
universe
with the actor's popularity and the
character's in-universe role as an
intelligent superhero with access to
amazing technology
bozeman's t'challa was essentially the
current mcu's answer to former franchise
linchpin tony stark
so how is disney dealing with this
difficult and heartbreaking situation
disney representatives say they're not
focused on figuring out what to do with
black panther 2
at least not quite yet according to the
hollywood reporter
sources within the disney corporation
have stated that the company is quote
processing the grief of a loved one and
paying homage to bozeman
as such they have no immediate plans to
shift focus to the black panther sequel
and aren't offering up any details about
what such a sequel would even look like
as of the making of this video
bozeman wanted to keep his illness as
private as possible
as such only a few people outside his
family knew about his cancer diagnosis
and subsequent battle at all
the mcu at large in fact was so deeply
in the dark about bozeman's situation
that the news only reached marvel head
honcho kevin feige's inbox on the day
the black panther actor died
as such the mcu's reaction to bozeman's
death was that of stunned heartbreak
followed by touching moments of their
beloved co-star and friend
robert downey jr even called bozeman and
his achievements the high point of the
entire mcu
black panther is hands down it is the
crowning achievement of the marvel
universe
the iron man star elaborated to good
morning america it was the one where
people got to vote with their ticket
sales and say
we require this overdue diversity at
some point disney and marvel executives
will have to lift the veil of sorrow and
ask themselves the difficult question
how should things go forward without
bozeman
i am not ready to be without you
disney has faced this uniquely tragic
situation before unfortunately
in 2016 the company had to figure out
how to proceed with the rise of
skywalker when the esteemed carrie
fisher who played princess leia died at
60.
in the same vein universal had to
painstakingly recreate paul walker when
the actor passed away in a car accident
as shooting fast and furious 7 was
taking place
however bozeman was the star of his own
incredibly successful movie and he was a
major player in the notoriously
interconnected mcu in general
while disney could cancel black panther
2 and quietly write t'challa out of the
mcu
seeing as the first movie was a cultural
critical and financial success and that
bozeman's death will have to be
addressed in some fashion
some believe that's an unlikely outcome
other observers think that the company
could try to replace bozeman with
another actor but that's bound to cause
a massive outcry
and for good reason knowing this many
think a better option might be to take a
page from the comic books and hand the
black panther mantle to shuri t'challa's
younger sister played by leticia wright
the tenacious and tech savvy shuri is a
popular character and are ascension to
full black panther hood is already
something fans want to see in black
panther 2.
this idea has even pushed some fans to
start petitioning for disney and marvel
to tap shuri to become the next black
panther
regardless of what's going to happen the
mcu and the world has lost a true
giant in chadwick boseman as black
panther director ryan coogler put it
i spent the last year preparing
imagining and writing words for him to
say that we weren't destined to see
it leaves me broken knowing that i won't
be able to watch another close-up of him
in the monitor
again or walk up to him and ask for
another take
our thoughts are with bozeman's friends
and family during this time of grief